So the next from that we
need to worry about is,
the problem of state estimation.
And as we were just talking
about a couple moments ago.
We can make a POM D.P. into a M.D.P.,
by expanding out the state space.
What we're going to do is,
consider what we call belief states.
So, the state that the decision
maker is going to use in
the context of a POM DP is,
going to be a belief state b.
And what a belief state b gives you is,
that if you tell me a state like s.
Belief state b(s) tells us the
probability that we're actually in state
s at the current moment in time.
>> So b is a sort of like a state,
well it's a belief state.
So it's like what we did
in the last example.
It's kind of a vector.
It's a distribution over states.
>> Yes, exactly.
It's a probability
distribution over states.
Yes, and so and that's going to
that's going to encode for us.
It's going to retain for us
the information about the history that
might be important for decision making.
>> Okay, so gets us all
the way back to the beginning.
Okay, so b(s) then, so b is just
a vector and it's indexed by s and s,
instead of being an integer
is just a state.
>> Right.
>> Okay, that works.
It's a probability distribution.
All right, that makes sense.
Okay.
>> So now what we need to do is,
figure out how this belief state gets
updated as we take actions in the world.
>> Okay.
>> So the way we're going to think about
that is, we're in some belief state,
we choose an action.
The world gives us back
an observation and we need now,
a new belief state to
be formed from that.
>> Okay, so that's exactly parallel to
the, we're in a state we took an action,
then we got into another state.
>> Right, so
what we really are doing here is,
we're building up
a notion of a belief MDP.
So, we're going to turn
the POMDP into a kind of MDP,
specifically the belief MDP.
Where the states of the belief MDP are
probability distributions over states of
the underlying MDP in the POMDP.
>> Okay, sounds good.
So, an aside Michael,
is if reward is a function of state.
Which it sometimes is, so
you should be able to use that
to update your belief state.
>> Right, so
in what we're going to be talking about,
the reward is essentially not observed.
But of course in reality, if you have
a learner that's in some environment and
it's making observations.
And getting some reward back,
it can actually,
and if it knows something about how
that reward is being generated.
It can use that as a kind of observation
and so, we can essentially assume that
the observation has whatever information
might be in the reward in it.
>> Right, so in fact,
the observation is whatever sub teachers
you get to see plus the reward.
>> Yeah,
I've seen some people write it this way,
where you say that the reward is
actually something about the observable.
You know, all the reward you get,
is extracted from what you observe and
so, anything that you
model in the POMDP.
As being reward relevant, has to
actually show up in the observation.
>> Right, that seems reasonable.
>> Right, otherwise you can't
learn if you can't observe it.
>> Right, that makes perfect sense.
>> All right, so we need to do is,
derive how we get this probability
distribution over states b prime
from the old belief state.
The action, the observation, and
whatever quantities in
the POMDP that we have.
So, what we need to figure out is,
in this new belief state,
after we've taken action a.
And seen observation z, what is the
probability that we're in state S prime?
And so, we're going to have to
do some kind of probabilistic,
I guess inference or
derivation to work that out.
>> Sure,
we ought to be able to do that right,
because we have all the quantities
that we need in the POMDP, I think.
>> Well that's the hope, so we want
the probability of the next state,
given that we're in a belief state.
Took an action and made an observation.
So, can we manipulate this expression
using the laws of probability
to make sense out of it?
Sure.
The good answer.